herr präsident herr minister exzellenzen
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
verehrte damen meine herren vor allen
dingen lieber michael lieber kai
westerwelle guido westerwelle ist tot
diese nachricht hat mich hat uns alle
getroffen und berührt seine familie
seine freunde seine wegbegleiter seine
gegner und millionen denen er kraft
gegeben hat mit seinem kampf gegen eine
heimtückische krankheit
guido westerwelle ist tot
diesen satz im grunde bis heute kann ich
gar nicht begreifen
er soll nicht mehr da sein der so lange
zeit immer da war der ein markanter
orientierungspunkt politischer debatten
gewesen war
der eine ganze generation inspiriert hat
oder provoziert
guido westerwelle wurde erwachsen zu
einer zeit als von no future und null
bock die rede war
er hat sein leben dazu als gegenentwurf
geführt er war ein optimist der uns zum
gebrauch unserer freiheit ermuntern
wollte guido hat oft über seine
schulzeit in bonn gesprochen über lehrer
die sich lieber unterhalten als
unterrichten wollten
er hat berichte die viel anstrengungen
es ihn gekostet hat von der realschule
über das abitur den weg bis zum
promovierten juristen fortzusetzen
in der politiker westerwelle später
davon sprach leistung müsse einen
unterschied machen
dann meinte er auch diesen dann meinte
er seinen weg manche haben diese sätze
als ausdruck der sozialen härte
interpretiert die rheinstädter
wegbegleiter des liberalismus sei sie
haben den liberalismus missverstanden
und sie haben
guido westerwelle missverstanden er hat
sich eben nicht mit den ohnehin starken
gemein machen wollen sondern sein
menschenbild war voller vertrauen und
zutrauen nämlich in die kraft eines
jeden einzelnen
ihn hat nicht interessiert woher jemand
kam sondern
wohin er wollte als er 1980 begann sich
politisch zu engagieren gehörte er
folgerichtig zu den gründer und einer
neuen jugendorganisation unserer partei
weil die vorherige sich weit von den
idealen des liberalismus entfernt hatte
weit von dem entfernt hatte was guido
westerwelle bürgerliche werte nannte
zukunftsvertrauen freiheitsliebe
toleranz respekt vor individueller
leistung und eigentum
bald wurde er einer der ersten
vorsitzenden der jungen liberalen
1994 wurde guido generalsekretär unserer
partei zu einer zeit als die fdp sich
nach dem großen wahlerfolg der ersten
gesamtdeutschen wahl in der koalition
konzeptionell erschöpft hatte als
schmied von koalitionskompromisse ihr
eigenes profil verloren hatte
mit den wiesbadener grundsätzen hat er
der liberalen partei damals ein
wertegerüst zurückgegeben er warnte vor
einer gefälligkeitspolitik die in der
gegenwart mehr verteilt als die
gesellschaft an wohlstand zu erarbeiten
in der lage ist auch das war kein kaltes
und hartes konzept es war das plädoyer
eines der jüngsten spitzenpolitiker der
republik für gerechtigkeit zwischen den
generationen
wir wissen dass diese gedanken auch nach
20 jahren nichts an aktualität verloren
haben als generalsekretär wurde er dann
auch einer breiteren öffentlichkeit
bekannt er prägte das bild der fdp in
diesem amt und dieses amt prägte sein
bild das sich die öffentlichkeit von ihm
machte
die in unserem land tief verwurzelte
sehnsucht nach erlösung von politik und
parteien streit war ihm ein graus
er glaubte an die macht von rede und
gegenrede
denn er wusste dass nur aus der debatte
heraus ein wettbewerb der ideen entsteht
der alternativen aufzeigt die am ende
wie demokratischen wahl entscheidungen
ihren eigentlichen sinn schenken
während alle
parteien gleich und geben sie dieselben
antworten würde schließlich im prinzip
auch eine einzige genügend rede und
gegenrede verlangen nach abgrenzung
guido scheute bei seinen politischen
botschaften die zuspitzung nicht uns
vorsichtig zu sagen
er provozierte um zu bewegen
er wollte die debatte und er führte sie
lieber scharf als dass sie nicht geführt
würden er konnte laut sein und der
konnte sprechen
deshalb haben ihn manche ein
lautsprecher genannt in wahrheit ist mit
ihm die stimme des liberalismus
unüberhörbar geworden
das hat zustimmung und widerstand
hervorgerufen in jedem fall aber die
klarheit die die parlamentarische
demokratie braucht polarisierung war für
ihn nicht das ziel selbst nicht der
zweck an sich
es war ein stilmittel zur schärfung des
profils unserer partei
einige beobachter begann daher begannen
daher den fehler den politischen redner
guido westerwelle mit der persönlichkeit
zu verwechseln
sie glaubten dass wir so brillant
schwarz und weiß in der rede
unterscheiden könnte das der auch nur in
schwarz und weiß denken könne ein irrtum
und zugleich ein unfreiwilliges
kompliment er hat in der sache niemanden
geschont wie auch er ja niemals geschont
wurde
er hat die auseinandersetzung aber nie
als unversöhnliche feindschaft geführt
gregor gysi sein kollege als
fraktionsvorsitzende hat das dieser tage
in bewegender weise ausgedrückt er besaß
humor und benahmen sich auf meiner
fraktion und mir gegenüber von anfang an
tolerant wohlwollend und immer
gesprächsbereit
und weiter jeder weiß dass guido
westerwelle gut reden konnte kaum jemand
weiß dass er auch gut zu hören konnte im
wahljahr 1998 erneuerte guido das bild
einer eigenständigen fdp die in einer
äquidistanz wie er sagte zu den größeren
parteien arbeiten sollte er hatte den
mut auszusprechen dass die nach kohl
zeit begonnen habe wohlgemerkt vor der
bundestagswahl 1998 dies nicht nur zu
benennen sondern geradezu zu fordern hat
ihnen seinen platz in der
koalitionsrunde gekostet und später auch
fast sein parteiamt als er wenig später
vorsitzender der fdp in der ungewohnten
oppositionsrolle wurde hat er sein hat
er unsere partei aus der golfplatz
nische führen wollen raus aus den sälen
rauf auf die plätze so waren seine
wahlkämpfe zu den menschen
er sah die freien demokraten nicht als
volkspartei aber eben doch als partei
für alle im volk wie er sagte dabei ging
es ihm nicht darum unsere grundsätze zu
verbiegen oder zu verwässern
aber liberale politik so zu formulieren
dass sie im prinzip von einer mehrheit
akzeptiert werden kann
er hat auch in späteren aufgaben nie auf
das stilmittel der provokation und
polarisierung ganz verzichtet und er
wusste möglicherweise selbst am besten
dass sie ihm persönlich manches mal mehr
geschadet als geholfen haben
für die fdp waren die zehn jahre des
bundesvorsitzenden guido westerwelle
aber eine äußerst erfolgreiche ära an
deren ende wir in allen landtagen mit
fraktionen vertreten werden ohne zweifel
hat guido menschen geweckt begeistert
mitgerissen zumal viele junge auch mich
fehlten vorher junge menschen in der fdp
so kamen sie nun und guido westerwelle
hat sie gefördert
ich werde glaube ich niemals seine
anrufe am 13
dezember 2009 vergessen
es gab spekulationen wen er in das amt
des generalsekretärs der
regierungspartei fdp berufen würde auch
mein name wurde in den medien genannt
obwohl wir beide niemals und zu kamen
zeitpunkt darüber gesprochen hatten
und dann rief er abends an er sagte er
habe drei fragen an mich weißt du was
auf dich zukommt brauchst du es dir zu
liegt was gegen dich vor
nach einer minute war das geklärt guido
eröffnete mir dass er mich dann am
nächsten tag vorschlagen werde ich war
perplex und habe ihn gefragt ob wir
nicht jetzt zum erstens dass das
gemeinsame presse statement besprechen
müssten nein meinte er und hat mir einen
schönen abend gewünscht
ich schlag dich vor und danach machst du
aus dem amt was du persönlich für die
fdp für richtig hältst
so war er er hat geführt stark geführt
sogar aber er hat anderen immer ihren
raum und ihre chance gegeben
er ist zu früh gestorben um ihm dafür
wirklich richtig gedanken zu haben
guido westerwelle war ein europäer ich
erinnere mich daran wie er von einem
schüleraustausch gesprochen hat nach
frankreich und die schüler waren zu gast
bei einer französischen familie die
unter deutschen besatzungstruppen
gelitten hatte und trotzdem wurden die
jungen deutschen mit offenen armen
empfangen
er hat gesagt dass ihnen das geprägt hat
natürlich wusste er
welche bedeutung der binnenmarkt für
deutschland hatte natürlich war ihm klar
dass deutschland auf der weltbühne nur
einfluss behalten kann
sein lebensstil nur behaupten kann wenn
es seine interessen europäisch einbindet
im kern war die europäische union für
guido aber ein friedensprojekt
deshalb gehört guido westerwelle in die
tradition der liberalen außenminister
und insbesondere in die von hans
dietrich genscher wir sind tief traurig
dass wir auch in diesen tagen verloren
haben
mit ihm geht eine liberale ikone und ein
staatsmann der sich um seine parteien
sein land und europa verdient gemacht
hat in der staatsschuldenkrise seit 2010
hat guido auch im schulterschluss mit
hans dietrich genscher so entschieden
allen widersprochen die die europäische
einigung abwickeln wollten
er hat die von deutschland ausgehenden
stabilitätspolitik die sich heute als im
kern richtig herausgestellt hat
und die deshalb eigentlich fortgesetzt
werden sollte mit geprägt er hat in der
öffentlichkeit im parlament und in
seiner partei dafür gestritten
trotz aller angriffe und trotz aller
unsicherheit auch in der eigenen
anhängerschaft guido westerwelle hat
daran erinnert dass europa nicht nur an
preis hat sondern auch einen wert dieser
satz wird bleiben manche fragen heute ob
die fdp nicht politisch davon profitiert
hätte wenn sie sich in das lager der
euro gegner geschlagen hätte
ich weiß dass ich diese frage nicht
einmal gestellt hat denn deutschland
kann es nicht besser gehen wenn es
europa schlechter geht
von walter scheel stand der gedanke dass
nicht jeder ein staatsmann sei der das
populäre tut sondern derjenige der das
notwendige populär macht diesem anspruch
ist guido westerwelle gerecht geworden
das streben nach frieden prägte auch
sein blick auf die welt
er ging davon aus dass sich die
komplexen die asymmetrischen konflikte
unserer zeit nicht oder zumindest nicht
nur mit militärischen mitteln lösen
lassen
mancher hat seinen einsatz für abrüstung
und insbesondere für den verzicht auf
nukleare rüstung belächelt aber ist das
ziel einer welt ohne kernwaffen nicht
zumindest erstrebenswert guido
westerwelle war ein freund des lebens
die trauergemeinde die ihn am samstag
verabschiedet hat aus politik und
gesellschaft wirtschaft und kultur war
gewiss einmalig sie hat gezeigt wie viel
dieser menschen bedeutet hat und wie
zugleich vielfältig sein leben war ehrte
leidenschaften von denen er steinmeier
die kunst nur eine war er kokettierte
mit seiner herkunft aus dem rheinland
aber er liebte das blühende mallorca wo
er jetzt in eurem haus mehr zeit
verbringen wollte seine letzten
interviews waren die aufforderung an uns
alle das leben zu genießen und über
kleinigkeiten hinwegzusehen
gelebt hat er selbst aber lange nur für
seine partei
sie war über viele jahre sein
freundeskreis sein lebensmittelpunkt ja
und vielleicht sogar etwas wie eine
familie mit dir michael hat er dann aber
seinen lebensmenschen gefunden
er hat an seinem fünfzigsten geburtstag
beschrieben wie viel ihm diese diese
liebe bedeutet und jeder der euch
gesehen hat konnte auch spüren wie eng
ihr euch seid was euch verbunden hat
nicht nur mich sondern so viele hat
bewegt video guido in der zeit der
krankheit kraft gegeben hast und ihn
geschützt hast man wünschte man könnte
dir jetzt genauso kraft geben und trost
spenden doch wir wissen nach so einem
verlust
ist das nicht möglich für guido war sein
bekenntnis zur homosexualität eine
persönliche befreiung
er ging damit offen um ohne dass erst zu
seinem einzigen thema gemacht hätte aber
hat sich von dir ganz
selbstverständlichen länder begleiten
lassen in denen schwule diskriminiert
werden er hat dort keine lauten appelle
abgegeben sondern euren aufgeklärten
toleranten lebensentwurf vertreten bevor
ich sterbe wird schwulsein eine
selbstverständlichkeit sein hat er nach
seinem ausstieg aus der aktiven politik
gesagt leider ist das bisher weder bei
uns noch weltweit der fall aber ihr
zusammen habt gezeigt wie sie sein
könnte diese normalität
guido westerwelle ist tot
er hat das leben geliebt deshalb hat er
so um seines gekämpft wir sind in trauer
dass er diesen kampf verloren
guido hat die freiheit gelebt deshalb
für sie gestritten
diese aufgabe hat er an uns
weitergegeben
er wird uns dabei sehr viel